Je vous ai dit que Nichelle Nichols a été
importante pour inspirer les enfants de couleur
à poursuivre leur rêve d’espace, mais
elle est loin d’être restée une simple
inspiratrice.
Elle a véritablement collaborée avec la
Nasa pour en faciliter l’embauche de minorités
et elle a notamment recruté Sally Ride, la
première femme Astronaute américaine et
le colonel Guion Bluford, le premier astronaute
Afro-américain.
« And i Said not me they’ll laugh at you,
and they said, not if they hear you speak
5 minutes.
»
Mais c’est pas fini ! Parce qu’elle ne
se contente pas de changer les chose dans
l’espace, elle est aussi restée célèbre
pour le tout premier baiser interracial de
l’histoire de la télé.
Alors dans l’épisode les personnages sont
sous le contrôle mental d’ennemis extra-terrestres,
mais c’est une petite révolution.
La diffusion date de 1968 soit à peine 4
ans après la fin de la ségrégation et seulement
1 an après la légalisation totale des mariage
métissés.
D’ailleurs pour la petite anecdote, les
producteurs avait demandé à ce que soit
tournée une version de l’épisode sans
le baiser, juste au cas ou, mais les deux
acteur ont fait exprès de jouer le plus mal
possible et de râter toutes les prises pour
les forcer à garder le baiser dans le montage
final.
Et ça c’est que j’appelle être baddass
!